so failed former president Donald Trump
is continuing to build up the story that
he's the victim everyone's treating him
so unfairly the E Gene Carroll verdict
was unfair the 2020 election results
were unfair the impeachments were unfair
the Mueller probe it was all completely
and totally unfair Fox News is treating
him very unfairly and I'm going to show
you a couple of examples of this from
the last 24 hours and remember that the
Trump family may be the most
thin-skinned public folks that we have
seen in a very very long time Donald
Trump appeared yesterday on Ike so I
always am confused by what these shows
are I believe the channel is real
America's voice which I still don't know
what that is is it a YouTube thing does
it stream I don't know the name of the
program is apparently just the news no
noise they interviewed Trump by phone
Trump plagued by more audio issues
echoing to high heaven and says that he
has been violated as badly as anyone
there is no greater victim than Donald
Trump certainly I think I've been
violated as badly as anybody has that's
ever walked there's never been any
violation like this I've been violated
beyond belief he's been more violated
than the woman he was found liable for
violating in a Bergdorf Goodman
Department Store in the 90s certainly
he's a bigger victim than she is
according to him there's a political
it's really a political persecution
everybody knows it and there's never
been anything like it and frankly if I
didn't fire James Comey uh I probably
because that was a coup that was a whole
crew attempt it was not a coup and we
beat it but we beat it with we beat some
bad bad guys Unfortunately they haven't
been repercussions because people
haven't taken it up you need you know
that's exactly how I feel about much of
the Trump Administration they tried a
coup there were some really bad guys and
unfortunately there have haven't been
many repercussions that's that's exactly
how I would assess the Trump presidency
but he is continuing on this I'm a
victim parade and then continuing it
over on Truth social
where he said quote I don't know Eugene
Carroll I never met her or touched her
except on a celebrity line with her
African-American husband who she
disgustingly called the ape I wouldn't
want to know or touch her I never abused
her or raped her or took her to a
dressing room 25 years ago in a crowded
Department Store where the doors are
locked she has no idea when or did
anything else to her except deny her
capital F fake made up story that she
wrote in a book it never happened is a
total scam unfair trial
Trump engaging caps lock for the last
part of that and then just continuing
truth Central page two the Carol Case is
part of the Democrats Playbook to
tarnish my name in person much like the
now fully debunked Russia Russia Russia
hoax the 51 intelligence Agents FBI
Twitter files and so much more it is
being funded and tried by Democrat
operatives although this was denied by
them and when they got caught in the LIE
the Clinton appointed judge would not
let us use it in trial time will prove
him to be highly partisan and very
unfair where's the dress she said she
had and then Trump continuing
shifting his ire towards Laura Ingraham
of Fox News where he said quote Laura
Ingraham on Fox News just did a hit
piece on me there go her ratings showing
some polls which indicate that Rhonda
sanctimonious may do better against
Biden than I would when actually polls
show that I do much better against Biden
than Rob the poll you're looking at now
wrong your which has me doing far better
against crooked Joe was just put out by
Fox I am sure unhappily I'm also leading
to Sanctus by over 40 points in primary
voting watch Greg Kelly on Newsmax at 10
pm just endless endless meanwhile Barack
Obama met with a bunch of future
entrepreneurs and folks working for
non-profits discuss the importance of
service and also explored the coming AI
Trend you know it like you couldn't have
a bigger contrast between what these
former presidents are up to and Trump is
not stopping but he is still winning the
message continues to be
a b c d e f g that makes no sense that
Trump did and yet Maga continues to
support him and they will almost
certainly make him the Republican
nominee unless something changes
the weather is about to start warming up
and that often means sweating and
chafing and sticking sheath is the men's
underwear that once and for all puts an
end to all of that nonsense our sponsor
sheath underwear has designed unique
boxer briefs with an ergonomic
compartment built to keep everything
separate and dry and cool and
comfortable by allowing air to circulate
everywhere it needs to be no more
readjusting all day sheath offers a huge
variety of designs and patterns over
half a million pairs have already been
sold also check out their super
comfortable bamboo t-shirts sheath has
amazing customer service super fast
shipping along with over twenty thousand
five star reviews sheath is also
actively working with multiple
non-profits that deal with mental health
and homelessness which you support when
you get sheath underwear I've had a
great EXP experience with sheath
underwear I know you will too head on
over to sheathunderwear.com Pacman and
use the code Pacman for 20 off the link
is down below